today's episode is brought to you by
Ridge wallet now Ridge wallet it's that
front pocket carry and a while back you
know they had a man named Mickey and he
had cystic fibrosis and that's when your
lungs just they don't want to be lungs
anymore and they started looking for the
Lord but you still need them and Mickey
got on the transplant list and we became
associated with him here at this past
weekend and now it has been one year
since trick lung Mickey got them new
them new body bags then lungs you know
and this is the transplant of ursery
extravaganza so trickling Mickey's uno
ano con el arrow bowls us air bags so
we're excited he's here today Ridge
wallet they took care of his flight they
put him up here in Los Angeles and they
gave him transportation and pocket money
for his time here in LA he was at The
Comedy Store last night just checking
out the the vibes and here he is today
in studio Thank You Ridge wallet as
always you can support Ridge wallet they
got front pocket carries they got them
bags they got a knives that knife re you
know so in case somebody's coming at you
and you can you know you can get them so
they got that safety first and the code
there is Ridge wallet comm slash hitter
again that's Ridge wallet calm and use
that code hitter and today's guest it's
been a year after his lung transplant
we're gonna learn a little bit about his
journey with cystic fibrosis and just
get to see him here today in the flesh
ladies and gentlemen tricked long Mickey
[Music]
I did probably about most people did
purely in a couple of months eight
probably I better eight years of per
Bertie breath yeah you know eight years
yeah head to head I was a slow guy like
you could hear like one hair like on a
moustache and then it was three weeks
later I get you MIT I still feel like
I'm still going through do you really
like a second one so what happened so so
coming to that we got trickling Mickey
here right now and uh man thanks for
being here with us today man of course
man thank you very much for having me
appreciate it
making I've been in communication with
each other for maybe I guess probably
about 20 months and you are this is a
one-year now you have since you had a
lung transplant because you had cystic
fibrosis yeah that's right well right
that's right you got basically I mean
it's almost like getting a set of nuts
in your chest does it feel like that
uh no not nuts but definitely something
or a or nuts yeah I would say I mean do
we could get to the whole sexual thing
later but it's it's definitely something
like knows I got more testosterone for
sure really for sure yeah did you see
this so different than the last time I
saw you man but I saw you
yeah Tommy been to coma I thought you
were gonna you know maybe die you know
you thought you were I didn't just think
you were you said you might I mean I
think that people were rumor in the
crowd when we were there like kind of a
little bit nervous
ya know I'd have felt that too cuz I had
that you remember how you we would talk
about man my my skin just looked it
looked a little now off yeah you're a
little jaundice yeah look at Dundas me
like my eyes were dark and I was just
light light-skinned ya know and I mean
I'm I'm half Filipino so there's
something like that that plays into it
but I guess what I'm getting at is I
didn't look the best for sure man yeah
the best well yeah I mean you just
seemed like you were going through it I
mean I remember like you couldn't you
know I didn't ask you too many questions
because you get caught up in a long
sentence and you just you know you had
to like take a break you know you had to
like hold on to somebody's shoulder
almost to get through a long sentence
you know you were limited air yeah it
was tough man I mean limited everything
yeah
limited participation in life right man
was it really
absolutely man I remember the first few
I just want to tell you man one of the
first things that you said that I knew
was really important to me you know
there's a lot of people
talk to about this but I remember you
asked specifically she said what's the
most difficult thing that you deal with
the Cystic Fibrosis I said the isolation
yeah and first of all men no one's ever
asked me that before hand
really no no no no man that's how I knew
I was talking to someone who and I know
that you got a sister who's done a liver
transplant correct yeah she had a liver
transplant we were growing up and I
remember your skin tone I mean you guys
almost looked a little bit similar then
you know because there's just something
like yeah this is jaundice kind of thing
takes over the body I guess or something
you know yeah man I think that you know
your body just attempts to take care of
itself in the only way that it knows how
to yeah right I guess what I'm trying to
say is that you don't really focus on
your aesthetic right you know you're
just trying to live yes I live in regard
to the participation thing man is that
do what people are watching the ballgame
or something like that and when top
people talk about issues that they're
having in life are you really thinking
about someone with cystic fibrosis at
the end stage you're thinking about how
do I value the life that I got right now
right with the with the current physical
ability that I have Yeah right cuz it's
so limited you can't participate man you
can't even and and there's things like
for instance that the drugs are the
medicine made me half death for instance
my my left ear don't work so yeah
there's like there's certain things that
you pay this price for where you can't
literally participate as well in life
and you see other people doing it and
there is man it's hard to admit this
there's a sense of envy there's a sense
of jealousy there so you get jealous at
people who are able to live comfortably
do people that would talk about how you
know man you know traffic so shady or
whatever whatever it is you tired I
remember thinking I'm too tired to
finish like a big piece of cake or so
and you must be like this guy that's
crazy dude yet this guy over here that
you'd be talking to he can't eat it man
dude it was and this is real theater
dude too cute what a sugar dude next in
a bus is super real you would eat so
much that my stomach would push
my diaphragm and it would become harder
to breathe because of eating and and
then on top of that they're also saying
like hey to get the transplant you got
our hit a certain BMI so it's like think
of it like this man
cystic fibrosis in general I mean but
really so and at end-stage you're
walking up a mountain and as you're
walking up just put a half pound on
every mile is just right and it gets
harder you know you're you're in there
you're thinking you're halfway through
it's gonna get harder and harder and
harder man there's no there's no those
weights don't cut them off you know
right so you're saying oh so as the
cystic fibrosis goes on as the time goes
on that you have it it gets just
everything gets tougher do so it's
generative and and ability it's
degenerative so for people I don't know
it's a disease that's in your lungs
right that's right you got your bags
were what full of water what happens to
Nomad so I'll let you know so it's in
the pancreas as well as your lungs I
mean it's even in like the vas deferens
man you know nuts but what is that
you're not water yeah yeah yeah no
you're right man oh yeah did you take
Anatomy how do you know that no but I
used to look up pornographic stuff when
I didn't have any I'd look up the
discharge of penis and vagina and the
history and the factual books yeah and I
remember seeing that vas deferens dude
we learned in different ways but but I
know about that yeah you're talking I
think I'm reading in a book too but for
different purposes yeah yeah but we'll
hear it so you have that so you have
that disease and I remember when I saw
you last you were on the transplant list
and you were going through it
now this is the first time I met you
right here and if you're watching on
YouTube you can see that's over there in
Tacoma and I remember you telling me
this I get a couple of buddies that came
with you same jacket that I'm wearing
right now huh that's cool though yeah
dude I wear this almost every single day
I don't like wearing a lot of different
stuff it's just too hard to find it like
around your own house or whatever but
then so you you had it there and I
thought you look like Ralph Macchio a
little better Ralph on Macchio you know
because you couldn't move that good and
and you said this about a couple of
friends who had their I remember you
said man it's kind of crazy because
you know it's like you feel like when
you when people hang out with you that
they it was hard for them not to treat
you different no yeah yeah for sure man
I mean especially when you're an end
stage disease man yeah you're living on
the cusp of literally dying Oh Frank
sayonara they call you Frank sayonara
dude
sayonara I mean you if you get a cold
right like it's literally you might be
on your death but you might be dead Yeah
right and so and you half of you look
like you were gonna live do when I saw
you I would have bet you weren't gonna
live dude honestly no we'd never say
that I say that now that you're alive
can we go into some moments let's go
into some moments or so to drop this on
everybody how you and I know each other
Mickey right here yeah yeah absolutely
this is from his first voicemail hey yo
Co man this is Mickey calling from
Seattle so here's my situation there I'm
30 years old and I'm currently at the
end stage of a lung disease now my
current lungs don't have very long left
by about two and a half years hopefully
we can stretch them out but the silver
lining is that I'm gonna be soon on the
lung transplant list I'm open I'm gonna
get listed which will give me a few more
years to figure this whole thing out
that's [ __ ] Trickey Mickey dude you
know he's got them tricky airbags inside
of him you know he's got two and a half
years left on as long as you got them
least he's got them least lungs you know
and I had a bad lease on a car a couple
years back and it's not the same thing
but you know you only get so I only got
so many miles I can only drive I got
4,000 miles a year on a lease and Jesus
it it was miserable
okay I wonder how that's when you first
called in and then let's go to a next
clip here and miles you think I had my
lungs oh dude I don't know I don't know
man dude I was running three
hundred-plus were uk+ all I had to be
man we were at the fumes that point
you're at nothing yeah I remember you
just kind of given up during sentences
you got a little guy there you would
almost kind of hit him and he finish the
sentence for you what else do we have
here's another so that first call was
from February 1st 2018 and
you guys met in Tacoma and this was
about a month after that you sound like
you got them trumpets rolling man are
you feeling okay today yeah absolutely
dude I'm I'm living life man out of
still one to ten man I'm living at about
an eight point five right now feel like
it good that's beautiful man and but you
know I seen some stuff when your
Instagram and stuff that you've been in
the hospital I know like we kind of
texted a little bit about it the last I
saw you you you know you were in Tacoma
you were doing good I know you're on the
transplant list what like what would
happen man it's so crazy feel man I'll
try to keep it simple as short but you
know man
we're about with my lung with cystic
fibrosis the disease I have at end-stage
things can go down very quickly and that
is exactly what happened man I ended up
not to get too graphic I had that
coughing up a lot of blood man and what
happened was the the scare was that I
wasn't gonna be able to do it myself it
clawed up so basically I had to get an
ICU man and and I went through a very
life-changing event man and if I'm
really frank and I don't mean to pull on
any any heartstrings here but yeah man I
mean my family I am we really didn't
know if I was gonna make it or not man
and I've since been out of a hospital
for about a week in a half mile mm-hmm
and it's just changed my perspectives
man I'm really I'm thankful for it all
and you know what I'm on the upswing man
and I am on the transplant list
and any day now those ones will be
coming in there no way really and after
this event feel dude I mean I've never
felt so loved it's so crazy that such a
traumatic and tragic experience on the
other side of the coin then it brings
people together that's not learn to or
to another level and for me
yeah even even being out of it here for
the past ten days or so I like I said I
guess maybe I'm riding off that high I
don't know but i I've never felt more
loved and I I'm physically weaker than I
used to be
but I've never been in a better more
clear space mentally and emotional in
there okay so right there so at that
point you hear yourself now looking back
and you you felt like it really brought
people together to another level do you
still feel that like about your family
and stuff like that do that's hard to
even see sometimes but I just wash is it
a bit why not like hard bad made sir
dude cuz I think tomorrow Co I actually
know that I'm even realizing it cuz I've
known it past couple months tomorrow's
the the anniversary I would I want to
answer that question I'll come back to
that because it's it's impacted greatly
I think my relationships and family and
whatnot but I mean I used to share that
video with people that were in the
cardiothoracic ICU like a person who had
I remember a young man and he he was
waiting for a heart transplant and they
didn't know if he was gonna get it on
and I remember he would walk by so at
this at the rehab facility we're
basically doing laps man because we got
to work on cardio right if you don't use
it you lose it type thing especially
right when it's brand-new mmm you got a
you got to use it you got to get this
acclimated with this right anyway so I
remember this man and he might not get a
transplant he might not get his heart
and he would die and I remember sending
him that video and telling him hey man
this happened that video man that
happened my call with you was like one
to two weeks before my trans mean I
think it was one week before the day
before the transplant you guys had a
text exchange and you read that on the
podcast okay I got a text from him today
he and this isn't definite but I
shouldn't share but you know what I'm
sharing him keep some hope out there he
is on he is scheduled to get some lungs
tomorrow so how crazy is that boy he
might get them new ballast bruh he might
be running around on them new fricken
inner titties you feel me the mayor
titties them lungs and so he said he'll
know definitely in the morning I'll read
you the text that came in
he said bro I just read wha no he goes
surgery scheduled for two Oh donor just
came in man crossing my fingers new
hitters that's what he said
I said no way he goes surgery scheduled
for tomorrow barring that they're safe
for me and that no one else may need him
more than me
and that shows you what those transplant
lists are like I mean here he is goes to
bed and you know and he don't know if
when he wakes up in the morning if
somebody else will have come along and
something will have happened to them and
now those hitters won't be there for him
and guess who it is it's a man who od'd
who overdosed ah we're living in a wild
whirlpool army we're living in a wild
whirlpool yeah I remember that now man
get me some of this yeah man there's a
lot going on there yeah it's so much to
unpack yeah man there's a whole year's
bit about that and some very real stuff
but won't take me to this oh so you're
going in with your family you know like
and before that you had some really real
moments there family and it brought you
guys closer together you said oh
absolutely man so that the call before
right where I was speaking with you and
I was I was intubated I had that a tube
shoved down my throat to be able to
breathe I came out of that I remember my
dad looking at me and telling me he goes
because you changed you changed and not
in a negative way but he was really
inspired I could tell and what happened
was I mean I was I was filled with love
you know you can't I believe that I'm in
a really unique scenario where I've been
on my field dude I wasn't my deathbed
okay and in three weeks you got to live
life again
mm-hmm and that's it's wild man it's so
it's surreal it's crazy it's scary
there's full of anxiety all most feel
like you let some people down a little
bit by not dying I cannot in a messed up
way I know that sounds crazy but is that
crazy
now I don't think it's crazy but I'm
what I'm trying to say is do you feel
like that you could never you know the
Big Finish is to die Jesus man I want to
know how I want to get back to that
because I don't know how you died so
many people want to know that about you
well we
later but but what I'm saying is it is
there a thing there that like man it's
like yeah almost there is I know for
some patients that they have it gills
yeah yeah that's I'm talking about you
can't get at yeah you can't ever see it
all the way through you know it's like
you know there was one person it was one
person to one only and that was my this
sounds it's funny you joke around about
like this duties I went in there I get
the call I say okay what do you guys
want me to do they go a 1907 p.m. 1900
you come into the hospital or all of a
sudden military try to trick you they
want you to be there late that's
insurance man you get there two hours
late you don't get the [ __ ] deal that
was gonna pay for it what is in 1900
yeah this is time not years so anyway it
getting get back at it so I'm like okay
what do you guys want me to do and they
said just live your life tell normal it
was 10 a.m. man it was 10 a.m. and I
remember I guess ok I guess I'll go get
some tacos and go get my haircut and
chill out until 7 p.m.
yeah so now do you get the haircut
because you are for what you're thinking
in case you don't make it you're coming
damn it no I was thinking totally I was
gonna on the side that would have been
smarter though man well it was some
freak who didn't care about you cut your
hair down at the you know idea free wood
you got all her hair cut yourself bad
with that haircut yeah I probably would
I mean I'd have somebody tighten it up a
little bit maybe a little bit of maybe
it's not in the back what do you say
that let me let me let me get to that
real fast I went there specifically
thinking I'm gonna be in the hospital
for maybe 2 to 3 months let me get a
good haircut and and I want to get I
want to get something short cuz I had to
like shaggy hair and I wanted to be able
to breathe because you can't shower with
all that gear right and I was prepared I
was prepping and I remember the exchange
that I had for my with my Barbara at the
time the guy who's cutting my hair I
said hey man I want it short I need I
need one on the edges and I'm gonna take
it take it all off to about like a
quarter inch and he goes hey man are you
sure about that I said yeah it's fine
don't worry about it he goes what's the
occasion what are you doing I said I
might be in the hospital here for about
two months getting a double lung
transplant and he said ok word all right
and I had then realized at that moment I
go oh you know some people do and don't
get
it you know it was very blase it was
very blase it was what what do you mean
his reaction more or less kind of like
alright double of transplant oh I see
and it's not don't get me wrong I don't
want to get there's any expectation on
that end but it's more to say a lot of
people don't know man a lot of people
don't know like someone had to die for
me to live yeah
again like there's so much to unpack but
it's like a lot of people don't realize
the intensity and of the scenario at all
right you know again whether it's
rebirth in living a new or whether it's
one person had to die over an overdose
you can't die in any single way man if
someone stabbed you in the lung we get
in those lungs dude yeah no one wants
those lungs man sorry dude we have
punctured lungs you have to die
circumstances yeah a lot of motorcycle
accidents yes those guys give them up a
lot a lot of people decapitation stuff
like that yeah man is really you know
this guy overdosed his head you got
yours huh that's right that's right no
this is all over the place but let me go
back to this where so I could imagine
say you you know you're not sure if
you're gonna be alive right and only
talked about this candidly with you cuz
you you know and when we've discussed
this kind of stuff you've been pretty
candid about most of it you know and
really insightful and some um let me ask
you do you think in my view I think you
would be like you have to be right what
I gotta be candid man there's no does no
useless feeling like I don't know that's
what I'm trying to figure out like you
know like that's what I'm you know like
like whenever you're talking with your
family before it's like we I feel like I
would worry that I'd make all these
promises my family man if I only had an
extra week you know we would do this and
this and this and I promise I would
always be like this and then you get the
transplant you get the extra weeks and
you're just like oh [ __ ] it we got time
to kill now you know like not in a bad
way but just like you know that's human
nature oh man but it ain't human nature
for me right right at least at least in
my perspective because you know again
man it's it's a perspective thing you've
I've always been for lack of better
words held down by hell
man I would have plans dude I've got big
plans these days with life right and the
number one thing that always taught me
was health right eat at 13 14 years old
I was facing a daily dose of mortality
every Sunday and now now I don't man and
he do other people get tired of hearing
about that whenever you're young like
take me what's with her what's some of
that like like what is that
like you know what is some of that like
yeah cuz like you used to say when your
sister was sick she got all the
attention and you were kind of resentful
yeah like so like you being the center
of attention did you ever feel that from
anybody
no yeah people at home it's weird dude I
mean Nick that's a great question I
think that if I'm real with you man
this is vulnerable but I actually it's
hard for me to say
especially on something like this but I
actually don't feel like I receive I
receive a ton of love right I don't feel
a lot of it mm-hmm I don't feel a lot of
it and and I don't think that's
necessarily because the fact that I've
taken wrong turns in life necessarily
but it's more of um again man I spoke
about the whole participating in life
aspect of things there's a depth that I
have and I don't know whether CF related
or not maybe it's just my mind I don't
know but a lot of people can't level
with and so when I go out in the world
and I see however the world I see right
like I wonder why people people aren't
taking their own face into their own
hands man like III like I said uniquely
enough I have this at 31 years old I
have this unique experience to live life
again and realize okay this is what I'm
not gonna do you know what I'm not gonna
do ain't gonna work 40 hours a week dude
I I it's in the sense of like working
for someone I'll try to get out of that
I'll pay my time cool whatever right but
you got to realize fast man like what is
important to you and all these types of
things man what is important what you
want to do in life I never had a bucket
list but I things that I want to achieve
right and now I feel like I have that
ability to do so regarding the attention
I don't feel like I receive it in a way
I can process and feel it man it's just
it gets hard I don't think that they
come from a perspective that that maybe
is relative to mine hmm and it gets hard
it's hard
why because you like people just can't
understand what it's like to feel like
you like your life might be ending or
like like why like what do you mean uh
uh you know what I I mean it's a hard
question to answer what I really think
about it man I think it's just because
the fact that I get a lot of people
trying to solve my problems it will talk
about theirs hmm and again being in the
perspectives I'm like dude I can't talk
to you about your 18 tebow right you
know I can't talk to you I can I'll sit
there okay you know have the small talk
right right but but what there's bigger
fish to fry
it's just that but people don't realize
you know what if I can I can't cuss on
their [ __ ] man what the [ __ ] cares yeah
that's what I'm saying about your ATT
bill or or whatever is going on
do you like why do you care so much yeah
because I'm gonna tell you this man when
you live on the cusp of that when you
face your mortality every single day oh
yeah you start to realize real fast this
[ __ ] doesn't matter dude your traffic
jam at work many its sound is this is so
cliche and so stupid I apologize for
saying you're lucky you could be that
traffic jam dude there are people in the
hospital right now dude who are having a
hard time there people in
bumper-to-bumper with between the Lord
and the devil I don't know what's going
on hey yeah that's our Jesus that's uh
but but yes man it's crazy to think of
life like that I know we can't all think
like that
but to step out of ourselves I think
that I just have a lot of friends who
aren't able to yeah yeah I have a like
they was well a lot of people probably
just can't it must just be that we're
not wired then to do it that way you
know we're just wired to you know see it
how we see it in the perception that
we're in you know and once we get into
another position then we can see it it's
like I can only see the earth the way it
is but if I'm my astronaut or something
if I'm out there buzz and you know
they're all driven or whatever then you
can see then you get a glimpse of the
earth it gives you a whole different
perception on what's going on so you get
that by being able to you know mm-hmm
kind of go to those depths of not
knowing what your clock is but a lot of
the rest of us we just don't get that
roses it gave me that man yeah but how
do you get but but does that start to
affect you more because it people can't
relate to you now because you're coming
from a place where you're like you know
you know you're at the Year at the post
office yelling we don't need to be doing
this and other people are just trying to
get their mail out you know if he is
crazy like it doesn't matter you know
like I mean is there is there tough is
it tough to like re-enter Society kind
of a little bit it's interesting you say
that man I will never talk about it like
I know what this is like what I'm about
to say but I can see how it would be
relative to someone coming someone
coming out of the penitentiary for a
while oh wow
I mean I again or maybe coming back from
war yeah you know maybe not having PTSD
in a different way now I've had to let
you know a little bit about my story
through oh man and I've had like I grew
up with nine other cystic fibrosis
patients you know I was in and out us
yet all siblings know yeah back in I
mean you'd call a little brotherhood
okay okay I see better but a club right
right right we were all sick in that
generation in Seattle why spent probably
about three years in and out of the
hospital a Seattle children was a date
to a lot of kids it not I mean close
close man I mean my best friend was you
know he's my best friend but I did have
another two that I knew that they
wouldn't want to date do too I mean we
can't man we can't commingle to well if
my bacteria it learns yours then our
antibiotics kind of cancel each other
out you can't even have sex with someone
because if they have your cystic
fibrosis is could meet up and and teach
each other about the other ones defense
yeah yes yes as well as it create new
defense it's bad it's crazy man but on
that note they'll see oh man check it
like it's like Game of Thrones I mean
Game of Thrones Season one right now
Jesus so yeah yeah you gotta catch up
it's very similar
dude are you ready for that we'll talk
about that so are you really ready for
that commitment is eight seasons with
Game of Thrones
I don't know okay but I don't think I am
I to be the most commitment he has ever
had yes
like I'm or he's here to season four
haha
I'm already wondering how many get a
season four look look can I speak on
that real fast though on the UM yeah
definitely so you can even so so there's
a danger of even mingling so can i right
can you touch each other and stuff
supposed to what we do right right but
but the thing is this meant you're
meeting someone for kind of maybe the
first time in your life it's all my [ __ ]
this person knows what I deal with
oh it's interesting you're like 9 years
old yeah the subconscious takes a crazy
toll right we're like oh man I got to do
all these treatments I gotta cough up
all this stuff you know I love that what
you call football mucus oh when he gets
in the lungs right um am sounds like if
you don't have cystic fibrosis I would
love that I love coughing or something
spitting it oh yeah man Merson was
talking a lot about bio maybe he has
cystic fibrosis and we don't know I
could see next words in heaven and he
something seems he looks like here it
means something's wrong yeah something's
wrong with him but it also makes it very
special sweet yeah yeah yeah it looks
like his diarrhea like right under his
he's [ __ ] his pants all I thought as
I was grown up with these eight or nine
and I'm glad that we could keep it light
because the the bomb drop is this by 20
years old by my 20th birthday all of
them are gone no way passed away all of
them have died Wow
and you know I I don't relate a disease
or from other stuff randomly from the
disease disease and um I I don't like to
say cuz it feels weird but I'm kind of
the the one guy who got out right now
the one kid who survived and then when
my time to go came right yeah that for
whatever miracle on miracle it
eliminated that and now here I have man
right and because it's such a not were
those people kids on the list to a lot
of them transplant these days for long
service have advanced greatly within the
past 10 years yeah so I mean I'm 31 now
back when I was 20 they were already all
gone and so no man I mean none of them
were even maybe even eligible for
transplant a dude it's just it's so it's
so harsh to say man that's crazy man
that so so those so did you start to
feel like was there a superiority
complex
it happened to some cuz you know the ego
is very dangerous and I even noticed
sometimes it's like you know things will
start to make you it's hard for you not
to think oh I'm special as well you know
in addition to the other feelings you
can have I'm lucky I'm blessed I'm
fortunate and I'm staying the action of
helping others but there's also times
you feel like oh well yeah I'm the man
you know I'm the [ __ ] Ralph Macchio
just thing you see I don't I don't look
at it as a superiority as far as that
goes but I do say why me
oh I mean yeah and not in a guilty way
but like like quite literally you know
III why am i what why why me like why am
I still here out of these eight or nine
like what did I do to deserve living
continuously what did I do deserve going
back to our previous thread of
conversation there was one other person
in the transplant man like what I before
I got the transplant there was one other
person in the hospital that was
contending with me they sent him home
dude Wow and I'm I'm hoping that he got
long sitting across our fingers or
whatever but yeah there's a wimey aspect
and it's like the contender that show
the contender remember that most of us
are Stallone and I love you think of
that oh good Sergio Mora oh he wanted
Freitas snake I didn't like your mic man
Fredo from where New Jersey Rhode Island
baby or Alan what's his name Peter may
have heard of jr. right and then Gary
boleto jr. there's two guys from Peter
I'm afraid oh why couldn't he yeah yeah
but he kept Lucas and he lost a lot I
cried like every episode it was
incredible yeah the fight scenes were
like they did him all cinematic like but
just this weekend coincidentally Daniel
Cormier and Sergio Mora got into it on
Twitter because of how Sergio Mora was
commentating the Canelo fight they
thought they were fanboying out and they
were went back and forth like wow yeah
it was you should check that out later
so Sergio Mora is a commentator now yeah
yeah him and Brian Kenny did the Canelo
fight and they were just like even when
Daniel Jacobs would land a shot they'd
be like look at the chin on Canelo like
everything was about him man did they
like ever put you guys together or like
did you ever meet him and or they try
and keep you met Emma oh the interlude
oh no dude we up man cuz if we did we
try to kill each other
sure absolutely dude I would do this
liver let live dude I ain't gonna let
him so both of you guys are up for the
organs yeah that's why yeah and it's
like in words okay never gonna meet dude
I never want to meet that guy cuz he's
gonna because what if he's you know what
god forbid what if he's not here but
it's not here but I mean he likely is um
who knows but that uh yeah we'd knock on
wood and we cross our fingers and all
that you know but that but that is a
said man is crazy
again but you sleep in the hospital you
get the call okay I come in at 7:00 p.m.
I got my fresh haircut you know trying
to get it the nurses right and so anyway
uh and that's real now you're real horny
before you're gonna die like that ways
yeah I could see them whether it's
before death or after dude on well
nobody's I mean some people like you a
little they might they always keep
busting people for you know making
babies with the dead or whatever over
there knock you know they've always bust
every now at all bust a black janitor
from you know procreate with a bunch of
old senior women but my first girlfriend
I'm not black Janice headed by generate
all types of janitors black and white
and beige so that's a universal thing
people went off right but um but so
anyway you're in there let me get at
this one I'd say this real fed you
bringing that up dude Matt my first
girlfriend was a nurse and I was at the
hospital it dude I was at Seattle
Children's Hospital she was a CNA yeah
and taking care of me and then we didn't
you know started dating but she got
fired promptly after that yeah you can't
do and did you guys ever like hook up in
the hospital or now Wow
and is that is there a lot of sex
between in like these transplant Ward's
probably probably more than we would
like to admit I kind of mean that it's
like the Olympic Center it's like
Olympic Village or whatever you know I'm
saying I think anyway if you're there
and you got you know and you got the
death kathal on the next day baby I'd be
okay I'd [ __ ] a little guy bringing
the Jellico's you know we're all looking
for some love and so it that in I say
that as a joke but that's very me like
I'm is it hard to have sex when you
can't breathe that God dude but I always
found a way do
you always find out you can ask past
lovers you guys currently always find a
way dude yes absolutely
he's going long in a deal yeah I can't
stay in heaven it was hard you know what
I would do it steel this is a real power
play that I do huh
right before right before was all
finished up yeah I pull out I place her
hand on my heart oh wow to show how much
dedication I put into it cuz it was so
rapid and but then they like they knew
you're like oh [ __ ] he's he really loves
me
this guy did it all this guy's at 7000
[ __ ] beats a minute wow it's intense
but it's it but it's very intense it's
fun though it like it is cuz you don't
know what's gonna happen yeah do you
ever get excited is it do you ever think
your heart could stop and stuff a dad
there were times where because if you
remember I was coughing up all that
blood oh yeah there were times where I
would I'd be in the middle of making
love with a girl and start coughing
blood up yeah and thinking I'm like okay
I could die from this and but I need to
finish I need to have sex first finish
it up yes I do cuz like dude we got life
we got into duality or life and death
and I will always choose life yeah
always
and you also that could be what's that
group of kids in high school they go to
watch that midnight Rocky Horror Picture
Show dude you could have with that
that's you tell that story right in
there you could hooked up with any chick
that is like Rocky Horror Picture Show
man don't let it yet but I don't know if
that's my type but you're right that I
don't know if that's my type so so so
you got the now once you get the trance
plane you got a bag you got a pair of
bags from a let's go here let's check
out another video right here this is a
first first time we talked to Mickey
after the transplant let's hear it
yo what up bro yeah bro you got them new
fresh air duffels on baby boy man
dang man like it's no good brother it's
so good to hear your voice man dude you
too man you sound like a day honestly -
you sound like an adult now
dude you know it's great usually real
fast do my diaphragms haven't hooked up
to my lung flank eyelash right now like
literally I'm it's a silent laugh but I
am an adult I'm gonna don't know and I
went uh dude I weigh 118 pounds but I'm
still an adult Dan you come and he's
that lighter he's that light adult but
look out where were you at earth before
like out of ten and where you're at now
out of ten I could so it is really funny
man you know when we talked like three
weeks ago I want to say four weeks maybe
um you know I was like I think I told
you like I may be an 8.5 in life right
you're not a ten yeah dude this is like
you know not good we all hope he or
whatever man yeah it's like it can out
of ten if not 15 dude every day you're
out there huh every day is beautiful
dude so dude let me hear so you got
those new lungs now the person that um
that donated them to you this would that
person was a they overdose is that right
that's true man yeah I said that over
text you know in the sense that this was
what was considered a high-risk
transplant meaning that the donor had
been using intravenous drugs and also
spent a little bit of time in jail we
need boy you got a real G inside of you
now dude I got my street credibility
went up about a hundred percent at least
double what I'm normally had you know
dude you got them dirty moist
you got them dirty moist duffels living
in your in your sternum now dude this is
gay right he overdosed right tell us
about that man they don't tell me you
got a picture of him or not
no dude I'll tell you how it is yeah
I'll tell you this man there's this
thing called HIPAA which is basically a
Privacy Act right and so they tell me
what I need to know about the organs so
which is specifically this that let me
know let me guess
well yes yeah what it sounds like what
year how many eight years old the the
bag here Wisla little dude dude Oh
okay 27 hold on what about uh maybe sing
a couple bar do a little bit of national
anthem - what if I don't know that's Oh
we'll just do a couple bars of holes
here can you see pretty good yeah I
think I would go probably doing this
i'ma go twenty-three-year-old uh i'ma go
actually I'm gonna go with a 31 year-old
Jionni my original guess was 27 but the
national anthem was a little deeper so
I'm gonna go 30 you got to get close man
yeah when I heard the national anthem I
was thinking like Pavarotti I'm thinking
like 60/40 I oh wow so Knicks going with
those old bags that means you gotta
gotta gotta get them replaced in 20
years price is right for new yeah if it
is I [ __ ] up I want that blender uh
what are we talking here Nick yeah man
it's uh I think that he was 31 to 32
years Wow right Jionni right on the
frickin long money and here's what they
tell me man they tell me everything that
I'm supposed to er need to know right
and which is this that uh that this was
a high-risk transplant meaning that the
patient or I should say the the donor
had died and had been using inner Venus
drugs in the past I believe X amount of
hours whatever that Jesus as well as and
the big thing to take away is the the
recipient is that there's two different
things that I got to watch out for
hmm the two things were this hey he's
done IV drugs lately and also he's also
been had a history of a criminal record
okay and so they say that means there is
high risk for you could have HIV Wow you
get Hep C or Hep B mm-hm and yam and so
then they tell you that before and then
they say you still want them Wow
yeah and you can say yes or no yeah I do
now if you say no you're gambling you're
gonna get another pair do I got it you
got it another pair of [ __ ] you do
yes you do yeah
do you take her I mean you got it what
do you think what do you do I don't know
I like to I like to say don't hit me
it's like Price is Right again bitter
past bitter past yeah
that's probably the toughest game of
twenty one you've ever played huh I know
dude it's ridiculous man but my thought
you know did you think about it at all
oh I do I call I called my best friend
about it oh it's fun a friend that's
definitely yeah more complex I phone a
friend
What did he say I love this yeah yeah
she's all like here's the thing is your
friend Amy that we know no no I a me
no it wasn't Amy I didn't know Amy until
after the show made so many connections
out of the show man but right what's my
friend Deanna she's my best friend and
she she actually was the one who made
the GoFundMe page a while back and so
anyway she just she's a lawyer she's
smart and she said she goes listen I'd
say take him I'd say take him because
you don't know if you didn't survive
yeah so and I endure I go yeah you know
I suppose that's true and if even if I
get Hep C Hep B if I don't forget HIV
it's like whatever dude yeah I mean I
kind of mean that dude like oh that's
interesting is crazy so at that level so
that's to see this is a really good
piece because then at that level I
couldn't that's something I can almost
kind of grasp my head on to you like man
okay right now if somebody said hit me
do you want HIV yeah but like now I'm
good
you know but if it was like hey do you
want to live but also maybe have HIV it
would be like yeah yeah on denied right
right gun to your head gun to your head
yeah it means we'll shoot you in three
weeks you live your life but we're
coming to get you or you're gonna have
HIV and just will never come again yeah
well shoot you full HIV and you'll live
so uh do you feel any different do you
feel like when they put new lungs into
you that you develop any of the traits
from the other person if the person was
a drug user do you start to covet dope
do you start to you know do you ever do
you have any dreams you feel like aren't
yours like there's any of that kind of
stuff go on after you
a transplant recipient so like I told
you man I got the call actually on May
6th of last year and who called a man or
a woman the man man a nurse at the at
the hospital ok and how do they phrase
that to you literally saying dude hey
Michael we have that's also my name we
have a yeah we have we have a possible
donor for you and barring again like I
st. barring that you are the recipient
that is most ill and most fitting mm-hmm
then we would be performing the
transplant on you and that's that
getting back to what you were saying
though um what were you saying I don't
know all right we'll shoot that were you
gonna puff on some up you know you got
some that's Beck Levin I used to use
that man yeah this is flu take aside
propionate say so I do this every now
and then amen yes cystic fibrosis from
that what's going on oh I have my lung
something happen with my lung the doctor
said okay
but if you developed any of the traits
that Oh like someone who got it
transmitted you feel like you do things
differently that aren't yours now like
suddenly you want to slam or suddenly
you wanna yeah you know have a note meal
and this is this is not a joke so where
I was going thank you where I was going
with that was that uh the the donor had
his thing on Cinco de Mauro all right so
he I always looked at weekends like
these are big things for kids died
during the weekends dude we party on
Friday and Saturday
you know we party we party hard
sometimes party all the time but on
Friday and Saturday that's what most
people party and that's when most people
die and for him he got wild on Cinco de
Mayo you know and he did his thing Cinco
de muerto hey was he latina that's what
I'm wondering because I'll tell you this
yes where I was getting at what I've
taken yeah from him I cannot not date a
Latina girl really no I know I kind of
mean that dude that's not really even a
joke I like a lot of Mexican food a lot
lately
it's uh yeah yeah well they say like if
you have a baby you
craving of a certain food that the baby
could be that ethnicity a lot of times
and so I can't imagine this would be
very much different than that that's a
mate's what if your desire for people
you are attracted to is in your lungs
you know it's such a crazy thing when
you think of a I don't mean to take it
here but like almost a spiritual sense
to I have another person's organs
another person inside of me right now
yeah and so there's just no way in my
opinion that you can't take on something
this guy's DNA is inside him do you
start to feel things more
interchangeable like what does that do
for you physically having somebody
else's body parts in you you just
realize at least in my apartment it's
it's just a while experience you know do
you realize that first and foremost
we're at a time where medical advances
has made this possible right without
that I would not be here for one I mean
secondly again I do really imagine and
wonder I'm wondering who this man was
who this man was what life he lived
because here's the thing Theo many
people who go through what I've gone
through they die
yeah after transplant they die man and
because the organs get rejected right
they do and you have to take
anti-rejection medicine I do yeah I am I
haven't told you about this much but my
recovery I was in the hospital post
transplant dude for ten days right which
you're supposed to be in there for at
least two weeks yeah that seems like way
not that much hmm there you are Mickey
live baby right there
yeah dang look at you you look like Al
Pacino a little bit in there there you
look like uh huh Al Pacino you look much
older there you look much younger now I
asked raizy
you thank you appreciate that man I mean
that that has happened I feel like
there's so much emotional stress and
physical stress on your body I look at
pictures from beforehand I look I look
aged right and not not badly but yeah
you can see a pain I feel you could see
a pain look what do you mean you can see
a pain you feel like that when you walk
walking around you see that somebody's
just kind of like
can just kind of feel their energy
almost oh yeah definitely especially if
you've been fasting I could imagine if
your are on the if you're going if
you're getting sick if you're on
mushrooms things like that I feel like I
can definitely immediately tell if
someone's what's going on with someone
and sometimes even almost what idiot
what that specifically is or you get an
insight better if you're fasting I feel
like because you're so hungry for
anything and even a piece of information
from some Wow is like appetizer is like
is like a nutrient yeah it's like a it's
something you get you know what are some
things that physically happen to you
differently now that like that happen to
your body differently or that you know
or suddenly or different now the one
thing I smile at is move this a little
closer to you can hear me okay it's so
ridiculous I bring this up it's been
such a consistent topic do my sex life
is way better really like oh god I mean
enormous man I need a couple lungs in my
nuts there it I need definitely some
more fun I need some more I need my dick
to breathe harder so that's a thing
immediately that you notice and they are
you serious or not no I'm very serious
I um it's a blood flow thing I think I'm
right oxygenated right yeah that's so I
do have harder erections man yeah yeah
it's in its first thing that I noticed
that's awesome I'm other than the fact
that yes then I can breathe okay cool
great I can breathe but also but we
breathe too sometimes have sex right
it's like we need to do things right one
of them that we do what have you learned
as a mode like what are some things that
you now like an insights you realize
about life or about being alive or time
or anything some lights is some insights
about existence there you think other
people may not have the ability to
recognize because they didn't have this
experience and they can be good or bad
yeah that's a man I mean I would have
first asked you how much time we got
right but I'd say we got time here a
couple the biggest thing I would say man
is that
you got a really look at life and
understanding you got to build an
awareness to yourself to what you want
in life because it's not gonna be it
really is not going to be this status
that you may want to build whether it's
a little Empire whether its money I'd
say sure if you're gonna do that build
it and knowing what you want life
because I'll tell you this on someone
who's been after his deathbed and now
I'm gonna rebirth I would say the things
that are biggest to me are my
relationships in life the passions that
I want to pursue as well as the things
that fulfill me right I take the time to
understand these things and I would say
you learn these things real it becomes
every it taints your experience you
start talking with people you like oh he
doesn't he doesn't know himself she
doesn't know she's lost she's gonna keep
going through this cycle over and over
and over again and you start realizing
okay these are the big things that are
in life right now and again people get
caught up in their stress it's too hard
to look at and so I believe that once
you come back from something like that
that's all I'm gonna pursue you know
build my little Empire to the point
where I want to get the resources to do
what I want to do right right but if
anything exactly that do what I'm cliche
enough men do what I'm meant to be here
for right you know and and maybe that I
have a way somebody told me this
recently I said you know maybe you just
being you and living your life is a
testament of that someone looks at and
takes away from it
yeah you know what inspires them and it
makes them want to do something more
yeah there's some calls man I've run in
I've run into listeners yeah last week I
was playing basketball at a gym I
started playing a pickup game with this
other dude and he came up to me I
introduced myself as Mickey and he goes
hey man do you know Theo von he knew me
right away man that's great and I could
tell by your voice really Mickey you
know way dude man I got so many names
you gotta have a jumper after that man
you can't show what was great and I do
want to make note of this to you is that
I texted somebody about
and and I said you know somebody
recognized before the podcast and she
said how did it feel to be to be known I
kind of shrugged it aside because when I
took from my said to her I said what was
so amazing was his big smile on his face
yeah the thing that he said to me was
his name was Jordan by the way and he
what he said to me was man you just got
you transplant about a year ago you're
playing basketball like that cuz we did
we we beat him not by much right
whatever but he's like wow you're
playing basketball you're out you hit
this big smile right it is man and it's
fulfilling it's gratifying man and yeah
that's a way where you're somebody else
hears that and then they inside of them
it touches a part of them that cares and
they get to see you in real life
suddenly playing hoops and they're like
oh wow man that's so cool like I
remember hearing about this guy and then
Here I am here we are we get to play
together and be around each other that's
cool and not only that doing something
where you have to be able to breathe to
do it you know I mean if you guys were
underwater something might be like ah
who gives a [ __ ] you know but you're out
there in a place where you got to really
be able to you know use air it was wild
man that's cool man I mean even in the
rehab my physical therapist unknowingly
you know again I go Miki's my middle my
nickname people know me as Michael when
I was getting rehab at the at the
hospital this physical therapist comes
in my room and it says prefers to be
called by Mickey on my board right he
looks over he goes he points at me goes
are you you listen to Theo volunteer
chance I go yeah man why what's up he
goes you trick long Mickey huh that's
funny
it's my physical therapist man is a tpw
listener his name is Jason that guy's
you practicing medicine listen Athiya
the dark arts dude who knows what he put
inside of you hand dude and so there's
there's these occasions right now I've
connected men I've connected with a
bunch of people that and I wanted to
really stayed out man that the listeners
have helped immensely Wow and I mean no
I agree there's only people coming out
dude so many people just just give me
their support I had one dude give me
give me a message he was like you know
my son listens to the podcast we've been
listening I when we drive my driving
this
not listening and he came in the door he
goes dad dad makey got them new hitter
yeah and I just was so touched by it
because there's this father and son
somewhere out there I don't know like
Kentucky Alabama somewhere that that are
touched by this story whatever that that
feel that man like you've given me a
platform on man and oh it's cool man I
appreciate saying that well it's just
funny man because I don't know if I
would ever care about transplantation
unless my sister would have went through
it or I'd have been around it or you
know I had I had some experience with it
you know and then I remember you you
guys a skin tone was very much the same
color it was this kind of yellowish kind
of color a little bit yeah you know and
so and immediately whenever I saw I was
like oh man that's so crazy it's like it
just reminds me so much of my sister
when she was a kid you know right and uh
and yeah I don't know it's just you know
it's interesting sometimes how the power
of illness like how it makes other
people it puts this impression on us of
like of living or the value of it so I
can only imagine that being the illness
having the illness and going right there
to the edge of like not existing anymore
and then coming back from there like
yeah it seemed like you would have a
sixth sense as to like who's who's
spending their time that you know well
who's doing things in a correct manner
who's trying to who's confused who's not
like it I think it's probably why a lot
of like you know different cultures and
stuff over the years have done things to
you know whether it be fasting or
whether it be sweat lodges like things
where they just try to go to the edge of
their own mortality to see what's there
you know to see what they can actually
learn because those are things that you
used to have a lot more in everyday
Society before we got so comfortable you
know especially in the u.s. I mean we
really have a lot of comfort yeah
there's a wisdom there yeah there's a
wisdom that you can't learn just by
living life you get brought to that edge
man that's the crazy thing to me man
it's like sometimes I'll be having a
time like you know even just this
weekend like you know it's just so
retired this weekend doing no one shows
like I almost didn't want to get on
stage I couldn't feel myself talk I was
I
talking by my words weren't connected
with my thoughts I felt like I was just
like putting on this monkey thing on
stage and then they had like this father
son that had come down and it's just
like they're like man we're so excited
like I've randomly found an email they
sent me and just sent him some tickets
like at the last minute the other day
like it was from like three weeks ago
and I just hadn't looked at my emails
and I was like hey man what you guys
come through and and they were just
stoked and like gave me like a whole
different it just showed me the other
side of the coin it was like oh there's
you know like we just don't realize
sometimes the places we are or what
we're doing the effect they can have on
somebody else who's not even around
you know like whether if I may even just
you know in the morning I see like a you
know a mom and just give her son a hug
goodbye or the mom of the kid run back
and like I love you you know just a
little things we don't see you know you
see someone to pick up somebody's
something that they dropped that they
didn't even see him and put it back on
their cart didn't even know it's like
just we don't know what where the role
we can play in other people's wellness
you know or other people's comfort in
the world and but I constantly get
reminded by anyway I met the father and
sign up for the show and they were so
stoked and it just was like oh well this
is why you're here today you're just
here to help these guys you know get to
spend some time together you know and
then I live vicariously it's like I get
to be with my dad through that moment
you know through them it's like wow it's
kind of I don't know we're in this
little wall in this web we're also
connected it's it's it's it's crazy I
feel like yeah I think it's cool that
like Mickey got to share his story with
all our listeners cuz like lots of times
when it just happens to you like that's
what you need to like take stock of
things and reevaluate
but these people didn't have to have it
firsthand they got to hear Mickey story
and see his new lease on life and I
think it kind of just a reminder people
to live that way yeah without having to
go through the suffering yeah 100%
reminding people to do organ donation
you know like just the value of thats
thinking that their lungs could have a
chance to be here on tpw you're here we
have two guests and CEO today I say we
go for heart next yeah you got a [ __ ]
start doing drugs or something
boy that heart out
get a kidney dude I might get another
firm okay a violin or something yeah be
that jugglers cheating come on but your
your listener base man are the people
that support you Theo I mean there's a
special I know you know this yeah it's a
specialness yeah we got a special group
man is uh there's a there's a core
principle set man I do think that it
anybody that I've met previously that
knows me from the show so to speak yeah
dude I've had people from my past I got
like an old high-school friend just
reach out to me hey heard you want
Thiel's yeah
people that I go on people ask about you
all the time you and riff raff are
probably two people that people ask
about the most yeah you know a riff raff
and [ __ ] breathe ruff that's what I
called you and here we are having them
back back back to back weeks this past
weekend we actually have some patreon
questions for Mickey good and into
that's awesome Johnny's gonna he'll I
started to handle on our patreon
questions a little bit more we got gene
okay so we have our first question is
from Jacob Wells now that he's got these
new hitters is he considering any other
upgrades maybe calf implants so we just
yeah calf implants yeah oh man did I
think that I would go for if you can
pick if you want to vein dude no I know
it would be some new testicles really
yeah few testicles get smaller when your
lungs get smaller like too big to pay of
big testicles are they get bigger yeah
why again man I think that Vascular
Sheen it just happens man really I mean
you know and that's that's a ridiculous
notion I think that I'm good with the
organs I have but definitely if I were
to switch one out it'd be testicles you
want bigger ones
smaller testicles testicles are a little
too big I think overall so that's Jacob
wells right there my blonde Oh him over
from Oklahoma City man I met him at a
couple of comedy shows he has like nine
brothers and sisters none of them can
chop wood which was shocked me usually
somebody can if you have that many and
in Oklahoma oh dude definitely
alright we got our second one Tommy for
Frederick and he says tell Mickey
Congrats on the double lung hitters does
he have any plans for gnarly tattoo on
that horizontal chest scar
yes dude shoutout to my boy billy mayer
and he died actually he ate a bunch of
pills and i think died in a jeep grand
cherokee which i love those cars but he
um he's got it one of his lungs gave out
once and he got a shark like on the
water coming up out of his own chest it
looked like a shark like breaching out
of him into the universe pretty [ __ ]
dope and I think had like a UH like a
stripper on its back this is down near
like Florida you know what's uh
Pensacola so that kind of stuff is
popular the the tattoo idea I've thought
about a lot of things there's this is a
such a lame ass or to say but you're not
supposed to get tattoos after your
transplant man what specifically become
are you Jewish all of us there's a lot
of there's a lot of issues that come
with it man do certain things that I
can't do and it's the idea that there's
ink poisoning within the blood I say so
the idea in if I were to get anything it
sounds super cheesy I would keep it real
and this not be stupid and silly but I
would get a rose on my wrist hmm and or
something on my finger or Rose the Rose
represents six cystic fibrosis it's also
known as I guess a lot of there's a
story with it but it's also called 65
roses hmm so the Rose is kind of a
symbol to CF yeah and how many have we
cured yeah who's who's fighting it right
now since a fibrosis how are we doing
against it being nation' man we're doing
pretty well we're doing pretty well man
I I know that there's always new
medicines that are coming out right now
as we talked about man we've got an
acquaintance named my friend Amy and
she's doing amazing dude she's 38 oh
well really yeah I've met her at a
couple of comedy shows she has CF I know
and she you know she's obviously been a
big support of yours and she reached out
a couple times to uh and she said hey I
was thinking about getting Mickey a
one-year transplant gift she said and
maybe haven't come to your shows in New
York and I said well you know I know
Ridge actually Ridge had caught it's
talked about you know them front pocket
carries dude you know and there's no
bigger front pocket carries than your
damn lungs and so and so we all
discussed it an email back and forth and
then here you are yeah Ridge made this
happen today
yeah flu mickey out first class him and
his buddy from detroit came out mm-hmm
put him up in an air B&B
Gang Gang man you know what I and you
know what's so funny is myself in the
guy from Ridge talked about that
probably it must have been 50 weeks ago
well right after you got the transplant
we talked about it and we wanted to go
skydiving and you and I talked about
that but you can't do it yeah there you
have to well do we can let's go dude you
could do it now right Oh what's up you
can't do it at night dude okay well I
mean do tomorrow morning why oh look
you're the lucky one you can do it
whenever you want
that's probably waiting for me uh no man
I yeah I'd love to but I wanted to talk
about that real fast do Ridge hooked it
up did they Oh Ridge Ridge is great
that's cool dude I mean people I told
friends about it they're like Ridge
walls for the holidays yeah and to think
that seven months out I mean if you
really think no they did man they flew
me out here they got they held up for
lodging and dude he even came and asked
me for some spending money man every
yeah man Bridge bridge did me so well
and I mean I'm so I'm I'm so thankful
for the opportunity no it's cool man and
well they just kept their word it was
funny could he and I were talking about
it and this was uh you know they were
one of our early sponsors who even was
so supportive from the beginning and and
and and we just reached out to him
randomly when it kind of thought when
you know a couple weeks ago and next
thing you know they supported they were
like yeah 100% they didn't think twice
pretty cool yeah you know a lot of
people you know all of us we just we get
nervous we second-guess we don't know
but they didn't do that at all yeah we
got one more patreon question okay um so
Megan Daly asked what did he figure out
that he wishes somebody had told him
about the whole process that he would
want people who are maybe going to have
a transplant like he did to know in
advance that's a great question it
really is oh man could you repeat it one
more time yeah of course
yeah so she said what did he figure out
that he wishes somebody had told him
about the whole process that he would
want people who are maybe going to have
a transplant like he did to know in
advance
I would say that that it's not it's it's
I'd say about like 20% physical and
maybe the rest 80% mental well sense
that regarding recovery right and I'm
speaking of recovery right and what I
mean by that is in the CFM the long
transfer from the transplant right man
because like I said a lot of people
don't make it man it's hard it's hard on
you your body what I've been told by the
nurses it's probably the hardest thing
you can go through Wow like you think
like an amputee and PT or something like
that but once that's gone it's gone you
cauterize it's tragic but something like
okay let's suit up these new lungs that
are in you now you gotta acclimate again
the nerd your neuro has got to attach to
this it doesn't know what it's like
getting back to it it's completely
mental
right the hardest thing I've ever done
in my life was the first walk with those
new lungs it was it's excruciating man
because you know you you have to you're
relearning not just how to breathe but
man you've got these ascott all the
sorts of scars man I got like six
different chest tubes coming out you
know I've got an epidural I've got these
multiple IVs I got a catheter in my you
know yeah everything that and ins you
say let's take a walk because why and
why is that
because we need this to get with this as
soon as possible you need to work this
if you don't work this you know it'll be
it'll be just as good as the ones you
had taken out and so again it gets back
to to realize okay that you can I know
this about you man you said it before
sometimes you just need to be there
mentally more than you need to be there
physically right I mean that in the
sense of man I I wanted to get up and go
but it was my my friends and my support
that is able to say okay we'll step
along with you and we'll do this with
you right as in to say I didn't want to
start but you get me out the door and
I'm out running right yeah sometimes
yeah you got to get your feet moving and
your thoughts will follow that's right
Wow okay that's so interesting it was
80% mental so you think that for some
people is just too much that some people
it's hard it's hard yeah one of my best
friends is you know my best friend he's
he actually took care of me he worked on
the cardiothoracic ICU and he's the one
he can't take care of because I've known
him for 10 years name's Troy and he he
selected hand selected the nurse that
would take care of me right and and
getting back to this man he's talked to
me a lot about patients that he's seen
mm-hmm and you know everyone has their
own experience man but um a lot of it is
a lot of it is just again getting that
wherewithal getting that 40 to just feel
like I'm gonna do this instead of saying
you cannot gotta go through the
perspective of saying this right well
man you know I hate there's this going
on my life I hate that in this case man
I hate that I have to get this
transplant feel weak and instead you say
like how am I gonna get this transplant
done yeah you know instead of it get
this victimhood mentality out as fast as
you can do that you know ooh this is so
hard how am I you know what can I do I
don't know I don't know if I can - how
can i I think yeah I know what I'm
saying and that walk was so hard man now
what about this you get a new piece of
you know you get a new interior these
lungs right and you realize that these
are interchangeable almost between
humans right not very easily because you
got to have the drugs and all that and
you got to have them you know then
training wheel pills but did it give you
a different perception of like your
mother your parents that you're part of
like a higher that there's a higher
power that's really our parent or did
you does that make any sense kind of
yeah it's like when absolutely man you
know what I'm saying does it or no well
for real yes absolutely when you're like
oh my mother my parents gave me life but
there's any of us could have any part of
each other's life and still be yeah like
this did you have any did you have any
philosophical or faith issues or faith
stuff that popped into you I guess the
issue was that in you'd I've talked
about this about a year ago about the
spirituality aspect man the what came up
to me now again I I still lie in the
fact that I'm not very dogmatic but I've
had personally I've had maybe you could
say the same for yourself dude I've had
some too
many coincidences in my life for me to
be here currently especially in the
condition that I mean dude the year a 1
year out and again I don't I try not to
say this from an egotistical standpoint
but one year out and and having
something like what I'm looking like or
what I'm doing in life man I got a day
job dude [ __ ] that thing but whatever
you know yeah but that's a means to an
end man it's not just that you know I'm
healthy paying gee honey and underwear
so ok we're all doing things in a new
movie that's gonna be in theaters in two
weeks
oh but so what's how we do it to me on
DS actually yes life probably no yes a
week to week basis I saw me got my
underwear from a yes yeah we need to
look into that Nick but but it but yes
man again getting back to it I just
think that for everything to be in place
for me to be in live personally against
subjective experience it's just too
close to comfort to say there's
something out there that's gotta have me
going on right because again man yeah
there's so many people that die so fast
after transplant and then there's some
rare crazy thing like me where it's all
ten days and he's better yeah you know
what I'm saying Wow
yeah does it feel like there's any real
reason to it or do you feel like it's
like is it an added responsibility yeah
I used to struggle with it do you ever
wish like man it would have been if I
would have just passed away would have
just been you know would have been like
you know like sometimes movies it's like
the person survives and sometimes they
don't and sometimes a movie the movies
good either way but it's a different
type of good you know it's a different
type of special it's a different type of
value did does that ever pop into your
head no and then I you know like not in
an ungrateful like issue I get what
you're saying man I think that if
anything the big responsibility that I
have personally that I that I do
undertake is to make the best out of
these lungs
and not just that man but do it even
from me to you whether it's Nick who I
just met a couple hours ago anyone that
I've ever really come into contact with
that there's some sort of responsibility
that I take within myself to say okay
this person is rootin for me in some
form of fashion and I got this second
chance and not only that somebody died
and maybe he didn't die for me to live
but he died and he granted me that was
that way right he'd made that choice
that he wanted to give as long as uh
right right and now with that said man
and I could do this later I want to
reach out to the family mm-hmm but I've
gotta say I'm like okay I have to make
the best of it and not just in a way of
like oh let's let's party and can't cool
all weekend yeah but it's more of okay
you know what I it as an inspiration as
fuel as to say okay you got to do your
best now man cuz this is not just your
life at some point right somebody else
somebody else is in you do you know did
you do enough google research and kind
of put the pieces together know who it
is no that would be crazy
no I didn't I didn't kind of don't want
to know yet yeah because there is a
little bit of that right I kind of I
want to be able to reach out to the
family one day because I just like to
and have them be proud of their son kind
of yeah right you almost want to get to
a certain like place in your own life
where you can be like hey that you know
four years ago I got these from your son
it really yeah that'll happen I guess
maybe I guess obviously it'll just
happen when it's supposed to you know
when you and I talked on the phone that
was like that I was like dude theater
one of the reasons why I haven't reached
out to yet is because I don't feel like
I'm at where I want to be yeah yeah and
that's so crazy you thought like it we
wanted or that there was some
expectation you know you're kind of just
like the mascot in a way or not just
like the mascot but like you kind of
took on that role it was like you know
and it's all I mean and in a lot of ways
it's you know this here in this today
and here and you talk about just life
and everything it kind of like slows
everything down a little bit and just
kind of you know it's a breath of fresh
air as gay as that sounds and not gay
and like a gay where if you're sleeping
with someone who has the same sex as you
it's okay I've learnt one last question
for Mickey okay um so
do you ever my allergies right how's
this for help dude no dude that's that's
something that's really supported in
though you know that's what this is uh
okay okay I think you just missed that
heavy snort just definitely missed that
part of it yeah back in your coke days
you know I think people got that from
what I said Gianni hahaha look at Nick
wanted to you know if Gianni wanted to
keep his [ __ ] watch my reasons are
coming off real fast oh no no but my
question was um like do you ever feel
like now obviously you feel like you
have a new lease on life and things are
awesome do you ever feel like sometimes
that you like a random day that you fall
into like not so much a depression but
like kind of like a negative state of
mind or like you wake up and you don't
want to get out of bed like you still
fall into that and be like [ __ ] like I
just don't want to do it today and you
and like a horse or a same thing with
like the eighteen t-bill like do you
think sometimes fall into like [ __ ] I
gotta pay this bill like do you fall
into that mindset sometimes there's a
couple things on that man um yes
yes I do I I would do so many on and off
depressions before the transplant that
what I realized man was that at this
that my my sadness and my distress came
from a circumstance man I didn't realize
now being out of it I realize how Joe of
you how excited I am to live life not
because the fact maybe that yes I get a
second chance but I think this is always
who I was and to realize oh the reason
why you felt that isolation the the
sadness and always looking back and
never forward and is because of a
specific circumstance which is my health
for one and you know and secondly there
was doors months man there were months
when I I couldn't show up I I had a hard
time man I almost went to like a teenage
state I played a bunch of video games
yeah you know and I think what was
happening is as I was telling you Theo
man it happened so fast in in two to
three weeks time it's like a five week
period you're on your deathbed and then
go relive life
there's too much emotion that happens at
one time and I
think that that time where I reverted
back to this this status of you know
when I was in early high school or
something and there was there was a
second thing you noted there - that was
really specific to me man
I just I just feel as if again the the
big thing that gets me out of the door
is someone died out there and I got I
got to make them proud yeah and I tried
again I try to use that as a as an
inspiration yeah third times where I
fall term and I think we all do but um
but it's it's still like I I hold it for
a second let it go and then like let's
get better at it yeah trick Longman
Michael I didn't even knows Michael it's
new trick long Nicky keep that one in
the back pocket man I was like cuz
Mickey's got that like that mmm well
Mickey's got some pizzazz yeah it's got
a flex to it right yeah I think it's
kicking Mickey yeah yeah and I talked
about it to how it look Italian dude oh
yeah might as well
oh yeah you look way more Italian than I
thought you were gonna look when I met
you I was like oh it could be anything
this guy could be Slavic you know
whatever anything could pop out of this
guy you know you have that Bert like
kind of bird from Bert and Ernie like
could be a friend a cousins but you
don't say he's a handsome guy Ernie look
like [ __ ] Ernie what dude Bert was not
that much better what are you talking
about I think he was you bring up Bert
for us real quick he was a handsomer of
the two by far no well they're both
ventriloquism no they're not
ventriloquism man yeah it's got a
full-on unibrow completely he does do
look are you do you have never look at
Ernie look he has no brow do you know
what Arnie can't even close his mouth
dude so he's gonna be no longer sitting
probably because of the bad area
suggesting Bernie's got that not look
like her knee a little imagine it
and coming out like Brendan Schaub
Mickey that new lease on life man it's
inspiring dude and I'm excited to see
what you do in the next year yeah well
thank you man ya know it's just so
awesome thank rich for bringing you here
oh and they didn't even call and say
that didn't even call and say you gotta
thank us something like that
we had some gifts for they we have that
yeah yeah all right yeah you gotta be
able to defend yourself right here yeah
man I might put them on two of them on
my lungs just to keep oh yeah that's a
great idea so there's two bags right
there got a duffel you got a backpack we
got a couple wallets where you can give
your buddy Sadow's Sammy one of those
and of course a knife in case you need a
performing in your own trance not Ridge
does knives they do knives dude look in
there sharp brush so don't pierce one of
your new sacks dude you know so you got
that Ridge for ya man a couple front
pocket carries there dude they got some
good stuff man I still use my Ridge
wallet I still have it it's in my bag
but yeah well they did did it so well
man this place that we're staying at
it's been great so nice just to fly
everything they just been so
accommodating it was cool
did they they give us the word of the
honor to man and that's pretty
remarkable these days oh man thank you
bro I think needed a seat I don't even
realize that it's needed to see you and
just kind of like just have a just a bit
of a reconnection you know to what's
going on just with the podcast and just
like on a lot of levels man let me if I
can what does what do you get from it
I'm curious
get from what just whatever I have to
offer the way that I say things man you
said you mentioned this right where you
like man I'd love to connect in this way
what do you receive from me and my story
or whatever and what I'm talking about
well I think it makes me think it's a
good question makes me think about just
being alive and stuff like that and
reminds me just to have value
you know reminds me to think like a
little bit more in the space of
gratitude and that you know to see
someone else in here about their
struggle in their journey it it reminds
me of my sister saw him it makes me
think about you know just recognizing
that she goes through more than I
realize probably a lot of times and you
know she still does a great job as a
parent and
nurse and I don't think about that a lot
of times you know she's a nurse yeah
yeah cuz she spent so much time around
I'm she just there was nothing else to
be really you know and what else man it
just makes me think about the community
that's part of this past weekend you
know I mean so many times few will be
like how's Mickey doing when I was
Mickey doing and and I'll be like oh you
know our texture with or we've kept in
touch summer I haven't talked to him in
a few months I don't know we were
thinking about you know trying to get
him down for the podcast and we talked
about going skydiving a while back but
the bags weren't ready you know but now
you know they're ready I don't know it's
just it's cool man and it makes me think
okay good like you know we see you now
at a year and then what would your life
be like at two years you know when you
have this you know a little better
reincarnation going on yeah you know
it's like a mascot I guess it just I
think you kind of stand for kind of some
of the stuff that you know we think
about and feel about in here yeah Wow
you know I'm happy to be a part of the
mayor yeah so go put some pressure on
yourself and [ __ ] get it done Danny's
fast hands-on yeah these [ __ ] jujitsu
are slap people bro you could slide
people good cuz nobody would see it
coming you know yeah yeah stylin now
with the breathing to are you really
yeah can you breathe I'll interpret some
times that's our kind of real oh my god
saving those lungs
do you ever hold your breath all it like
often Wow would a psychopath other
people with cystic fibrosis must thank
you know dude there wanted to do what
I'm doing they are all for sure they're
like dude I breathe so hard all the time
oh breathe so hard [ __ ] shot no
let's not read that [ __ ] yeah dude
that's crazy yeah man no I be I do I do
I just kind of like sometimes sometimes
I'll just say but let me just try to
hold my breath for as long as possible
I'll just do that for hours dude like
how's the dark mm clock-watching
everything
do it that's a Dark Arts dude you're
here bro the Larry Bird of [ __ ]
airbags right here dude
don't give up on a Michael Jordan
joining the wizards trickling Mickey man
thanks for being here bud thanks man
yeah thank you guys Jionni premature
knit we'll see you guys next time
[Music]
a little town for me to set that parking
brake myself
[Music]